Have any glitz?
Anyone have any...glitz?
The Salazito compound has
to be around here somewhere.
Ugh! I need glitz.
Poor bastards.
That bastard chemist
Jericho Becker got 'em addicted
to his wonder drug
and then stopped making it.
Heartless bastard.
Aah!
[groaning]
No more screwing around,
Raduardo.
Make it right this time.
Uh...
Unless you don't know
how to make it.
Maybe you're just a fraud.
Maybe you're not
a powerful drug lord at all.
If that's the case,
then you might
as well leave right now.
[loudly] No!
[meekly] I am.
Then make the glitz.
I don't know
how not to make gliss.
Glitz. Glitz.
I hope Rad isn't actually
trying to make glitzotrene.
He knows nothing
about chemistry.
One wrong combination and--
Let's go!
[siren wails]
Firemen?
Oh, God!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
No!
[Sizzle laughing]
[crowd cheering]
Those Dalmatian
diddling glory hogs.
They're going
to hog all the glory.
[Sizzle grunting]
(Mayor)
Look, Sizzle captured
Raduardo Glitzcobar.
Go, Sizzle, go!
[Sizzle groans]
Oh, my chiseled face!
Well, at least
he was horribly burned.
All those Sizzle groupies
are gonna be flocking to me now.